they've only just rolled out of
restrictions in scotland's nightclubs
the vaccine passport route isn't one
they wanted to take not at glasgow's
garage nightclub
not at short notice i've got over 100
staff i've just managed to get back open
we've been trying really hard to keep
these people employed for well over a
year now furlough's helped us with that
we've done deals with our landlords
deals with our suppliers and now we're
going to have to go back and redo these
deals and look for more kindness just to
get us out of this hole in the past week
cases in scotland have risen by 80 per
cent nicola sturgeon described the
situation as fragile and serious and
said the rate of increase was extremely
concerning
on reintroducing restrictions
she said her government didn't want to
but the next few days would be crucial
in its assessment of whether or not it
should her covet secretary had once
called vaccine passports the wrong way
to go not anymore it seems for
nightclubs and events they are not
essential services and the nature of
them which involves bringing many people
together in relatively small areas does
mean that despite their very best
efforts and i know they make
efforts
their best efforts they can continue to
contribute significantly to the spread
of the virus this parliamentary session
heard from the conservative opposition
leader complete with curious farm yard
sounds in the background just a month
ago john swinney her cabinet secretary
for covert recovery said this was the
wrong way to handle it
so can i ask the first minister what's
changed in the last month from what john
swinney said then to her announcement
today douglas ross later revealed on
twitter that one of his hens had been
behind the parliamentary point of
disorder
schools are already back in scotland and
that has been pinpointed as a factor in
the rise of infection rates
so too is the transmissible nature of
the delta variant and the increased
gathering of people generally following
the lifting of restrictions
at glasgow's john paul academy they've
learned the practical lesson of taking
precautions we have our masks on to move
around the buildings and when we're in
our classes okay we have our event you
know our windows open and our doors open
so things things are different you know
but at the end of our lessons our young
people are cleaning their desks and
washing their hands you know that's just
what happens now can i have fun
scotland's infection figures prompted a
renewed appeal from its first minister
to the public to adhere to health
guidance doing the maths underlines the
importance of doing the right thing
james matthews sky news glasgow